8:47 caller from eight four seven can
you hear me what's your name what's on
your mind today
hey David my name is soccer so I have a
question about I guess a video that you
put out recently with regards to I guess
sargon of akkad and about how he was
saying about people on the writers being
scapegoated and I guess you'd produce a
video on that topic as well so I wanted
to talk a little bit about I guess
labels and how people kind of apply
labels to various people and
specifically I guess you know to people
that are kind of in politics today so
you can kind of think of various
examples one that comes to mind is over
in France evil clan who is considered
far right but if you look at a lot of
her actual policies in which she kind of
supports in terms of policies whether
it's social economics a lot of people
would say that she's actually on the
left but it wasn't I guess when it comes
to immigration nationalism stuff like
that you could say she's on the right so
how do you guys kind of think about
those things as far as like labels and
how they can be applied to individuals
whether in the past or in the present
well I think that you're getting at
something which is very relevant which
is that as politics shift over time what
is left and right and what is a
reactionary idea and what is a
conservative idea or a progressive idea
certainly changes so a good example
would be that there are lots of
Republicans from the 1970s who by modern
standards would really be much more in
line as sort of center centrist
Democrats so does that mean that they
weren't on the right back then does that
mean that they would be on the left
today well you're getting at a good
point which is the label is only
relevant sort of in the context of
society around the label right and and
sort of what else is happening on the
political spectrum so if your question
generally is do the definitions of some
of these terms change over time I think
the answer is absolutely yes but I don't
know if there is a more space
the question in there that you wanted me
to address yeah yeah so are there
certain things so I guess if we dig
deeper there are certain things that are
always on the left and always on the
right like you could say for example you
know socialism and communism are
fundamentally leftist Triton's whereas
you could say libertarianism is
definitely on the right and things on
whether it's you know so I guess as far
as social issues are concerned you know
obviously society changes and people's
opinions change so that's more in flux
but certain ideologies are certainly can
fall into one or the other category I
think that they're the two examples you
gave are good examples of how it's not
quite so defined and in fact in in our
video I'm guessing a lot of my TV and
radio audience has no idea who Sargon is
this is a youtuber his real name's Carl
Benjamin and we didn't even people on
the regular show don't even know about
that entire dust up because that was
restricted to YouTube only so I think
that socialism as an ideology is a
left-wing ideology and by virtue of a
Galit arianism and other factors it is
in principle a left-wing ideology but as
I've talked about now in multiple videos
you can have socialist rhetoric that is
implemented in an authoritarian
right-wing way now you could argue that
doesn't change socialism being left-wing
because it's fundamentally a perversion
of socialism it's a failure to actually
be socialism but then you're already
sort of in the weeds your other example
was libertarianism is fundamentally
right-wing well not really right I mean
I think that certainly the sort of
caricatures of libertarianism that we
see where any taxation is slavery and
there should be no regulation whatsoever
that's pretty much going to fall under
the right but then you also have social
libertarians who identify more with the
left than the right so I think even the
examples you gave are good examples of
why it's not so cut and dry interesting
interesting
so that's
that's a very interesting way of putting
it I guess like you know I guess with
things that they're happening and in the
Western world nowadays like things are
always in flux but nowadays there's a
lot of tension with regards to you know
how multi culture is a problem
multiculturalism is playing out the role
of difference you know groups of people
within society could you say that
certain religious ideologies fall into
one camp or the other whether it's you
know more left-wing or right-wing
depending on how open that ideology
might be compared yeah I mean it's not
even so much as a blitz not even so much
split among religious ideologies it's
that the more fundamentalist your
interpretation of the religion that's
going to be on the right I mean I see
extremist Christianity as well as
extremist Islam I see them as both
fundamentally right-wing authoritarian
ideologies right yeah that makes sense
all right very good very interesting
stuff tucker really appreciate the call
very much appreciate it a lot there a
lot of very very interesting stuff and I
appreciate you taking the time to call
and on that note we will take a break
we've got a fantastic I really think
you're gonna like this week's classic
interview and then we will get to three
really really good audience questions
that came in audience questions have
just been on fire recently we will take
a break it's the Friday show stay with
us